okay so the trailer for Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 is now out and in this
video we're going to be bringing you a
big breakdown of the teaser the hidden
details and also our reaction to it now
this is picking up in the aftermath of
the holiday special in case you didn't
check it out there were a couple of
things that were dropped in it to set up
the upcoming film James can even said
that the holiday special was helpful
because he didn't have to spend time
explaining why the Guardians had nowhere
and so on and so on in case you didn't
watch it though the main point is that
we learned from it are that they indeed
are nowhere after buying it off The
Collector though it was destroyed during
the events of Avengers Infinity War they
have fixed it up we don't know what's
happened with The Collector but his ship
was part of the star the Loki finale
with him flying past the camera as we
traveled out of the universe other
Revelations are there Peter romantis are
brother and sister due to Ego being
their father this was teased all the way
back in 2017 when a deleted scene of
mantis's mother was posted by the actor
in the group shot photo we could also
see her at the back back whilst ego
talked about all the kids he had finally
cause mother space dog found their voice
and we'll talk about them more later on
in the video now if you enjoy the
breakdown please hit the thumbs up
button and don't forget to subscribe for
videos like this every day by the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the Guardians trailer
we were gone
for quite a while
no matter what happens next
the Galaxy still needs its Guardians
hello we come in peace
now the trailer opens with the Marvel
Studios logo which then transforms into
the cover of the awesome mixtape gonna
stay that we will be getting a third
volume and after hearing how nisha's
song Choice was for the holiday special
I can't wait to see what he has here the
whole H trailer had the song D realized
by The Flaming Lips which was pretty
fitting for what's shown there that
focused more heavily on Peter and Gamora
realizing that they weren't on the same
page and her basically doing a it's not
you it's me like like literally that now
the song contains the lyrics Do you
realize you have the most beautiful face
do you realize we're floating in space
bit on the nose for for what was shown
but hey I appreciate that gun never goes
with the most obvious pop songs cause we
have to hear painted black or Sympathy
for the Devil one more time I'm gonna
lose it now for this teaser we get the
song in the meantime by spacehog this is
very much about someone searching for a
meaning to life and discovering that
whatever they do will push them through
as allusions to anxiety and fear of
death and how this can be a driving
force we see the Guardians returning to
Earth and they approach New York which
we can tell by the Statue of Liberty
they come across the neighborhood that's
filled with hybrids likely created by
the high evolutionary they then walk
down the ramp and this shot Echoes
several from their prior movies now
gruders come a long way since being a
teen in the last handful of films he's
way bigger and bulkier now and Vin
Diesel has said in several interviews
that the film will have him coming forth
as Emperor Groot this is a big version
for the character and it's kind of like
the final form of him which makes sense
for this being the final movie they say
that they come in peace but Drax ends up
smacking a ball off the little hybrid's
head like it's that like button this
starts a big fight and we cut to quill
in space listening to music and clearly
thinking about Gamora
thank you
don't forget
where we came from
[Music]
we have been running
our whole lives
I'm done running there was a trailer
shown a Comic-Con earlier in the air and
like most of the ones that debut in Hall
h there were some shots that aren't
included in this final release I'll talk
about what they are later on in the
video but I thought I'd just dropped
that up top in case you're like what the
hell is he talking about that's not in
the trailer anyway the movie's very much
gonna pick up on the plot threads that
were left dangling at the end of
Avengers end game with the Guardians
searching for Gamora the mcu's had a bit
of a tumultuous time is that a word
mcu's had a bit of a tumultuous time
during their production due to James
Gunn being fired and then rehired by
Disney to finish off the film originally
he was meant to be dropping this before
love and thunder and this was the film
that was gonna feature Thor it would
have given him a bit more urgency with
them immediately heading out into space
to find Gamora but instead they had to
have them at the start of his last movie
to set up him going off to fight Gore I
think it's given them a bit of a
distance though which has allowed Gamora
to set up her own group there is a gang
of ravagers who the guardians will be
meeting early on due to nebulous setting
up a meeting with them the sisters of
course talked it out during endgame and
clearly set up a way that they could
contact each other it was actually a
deleted scene in endgame where Gamora
left the battlefield after everyone was
dusted but I think this was removed to
keep up the mystery that she might have
been wiped out with Thanos Gamora is
very much a woman out of time similar to
Captain America I think it'll be
interesting to see how she's found
things in the future but it's not too
far in the future I'd say like 10 years
but but still a lot can change if you
look back the Crazy Frog used to be
popular now Gamora is known as one of
the fiercest women in the galaxy and it
makes sense that she'd be able to get
people to follow her whether she will be
working with the Guardians once more but
she's making it very clear to Peter that
she isn't the person he fell in love
with I think one of the most
heartbreaking ideas at the center of
this movie is that she's right we saw
her in Multiverse of Madness that
strange had to come to grips with the
fact that Christine was off with someone
else and though there were others out
there he couldn't be with them I
actually think that might be the case
here with the pair not actually ending
up with each other due to their lives
being on different tangents Peter would
always have in the back of his mind that
this isn't the Gamora he fell in love
with no matter how hot he tries even
shows her a Polaroid of a pair because
he's trying to force her to remember the
life that they had I love that they go
with a polaroid for this as Peter of
course got abducted in the 80s so it
makes sense that he'd gravitate towards
using old Tech with her the story is
obviously going to focus on quilling
Gamora learning to love each other but I
think it would be way more heartbreaking
to discover that they just don't connect
with each other one of the big
complaints about the Multiverse is that
death doesn't really matter because
people can just come back I think
something like this would be needed to
add actual Stakes to the returns and
shows that it's not just to fix
everything cop out to bring the
characters back I also love the subtle
stuff they do with gamora's design as
well to show that it's a slightly more
Rough and Ready version of the character
not only has she been with the ravages
for some time but she's not been through
the love story that the original version
did has a couple of flicks out from The
Fringe and she seems a bit less groomed
than she has been in the past nothing
major I'm not slagging the lass off but
there are these little touches that
really add to her being slightly
different but he just wants to be happy
like how he once was and it's a big
thing for the characters to go through
now mantis is the one talking to Peter
while Cisco's on and she tells him not
to forget where they came from Peter
romantis have their relationship of
being siblings out now and it's very
similar to Gamora and nebulous both had
a father figure who wanted to force
their will on the universe and it's
going to be interesting to see if they
tackle this idea in the film at this
point we see a baby raccoon on earth
that is obviously rocket we've nailed
that Easter egg at least at least we've
got that one right obviously his past
has been teased there before but this
film will answer the question of what
exactly happened to him rocket was
abducted when he was younger and
experimented on by none other than the
high evolutionary case you don't know
who he is this is a character called
Herbert Windham who was born in
Manchester just down the road one not
that just down the road but near me
money in the building anyway after
debuting in the Mighty Thor issue 133
Herbert took an interest in the work of
Nathaniel Essex aka Mr Sinister he
started carrying out genetic experiments
and even built a device known as a
genetic accelerator that sped up the
evolution process Evolution doesn't
really work like that but you know what
I mean what do you mean explain well
what a well a raccoon is as evolved as
you are because Evolution weeds are the
ones who aren't strong enough to survive
in certain environments the ones that
flourish there then can have children
and pass on their genes to them they're
the ones are weeded out and you get the
point and you basically end up with a
species that's perfect but for where it
is due to mutations say kids you always
learn something here now over the
decades the high evolutionary has
created several atrocities and he spread
Dalmatians with chimpanzees and lots of
crazy animals I'm guessing that he's had
a number of failures but that rocket
will be the one who works and thus he'll
be trying to get him once more in order
to unlock the secrets of how to create
more hybrids interestingly this film
will have a lot of characters in it that
have been experimented on firstly we
have Cosmo who we got to see more of in
the recent holiday special after the
collector's base was destroyed in the
first movie the dog was freed and we
heard it speak in the special whilst
demonstrating its telekinetic Powers
voiced by Maria bakalova she's back all
over this movie too and will be playing
a much bigger role during the Space Race
the Russians sent several dogs into the
Stars to see what the effects of travel
would have on a living creature the
first to orbit the Earth was like it and
she did so in Sputnik 2. sadly the dog
died due to overheating because of the
stress of the journey caused but the
Soviets did manage to bring other dogs
back as part of their program Cosmo is
gonna have been gone a long time and
using Universal translator the group
will be able to talk to her I don't know
if the dog is still alive from the 60s
but time obviously works differently in
space James gonna say that the movie
will be be one of the saddest MCU films
ever and I do have a feeling that
potentially either Cosmo or rocket will
die I don't know how many years a little
guy is left but either way we're going
to be getting a big showdown between him
and his creator might actually come to
accept that he's in fact a raccoon you
are a raccoon mate accept it looking at
his face he has what appears to be metal
Under the Skin and it looks like the
cybernetic Parts on his back Runway deep
air it's not all doom and gloom though
as we do see Lila and the teaser too
this is the love of Rocket's life and
it's such a cool moment seeing them
together the teaser does have some
horrifying shots too and a scalpel with
blood on it I'm guessing the high
evolutionary uses there's also Adam
Warlock who will be played by Will
Poulter similar to Rocket and Cosmo he's
been through experimentation himself and
we last left him being created at the
end of Guardians volume 2. in the comics
this is the character that's tied
heavily in with the Infinity Stones and
he's actually a big adversary of Thanos
he's also got allegiances with Pippa the
troll who was teased at the end of the
eternals I have a feeling that Adam will
be popping up in the next eternals
project too and with Eros being thanos's
brother they can kind of time in with
that now he was named Adam after the
first man however the name warlock was
given to him by the high evolutionary
it's even possible that he might be
working alongside him early on or we
could get an appearance Once More by the
group The Sovereign now it seems like
they've changed the spacesuit style as
we see way more colorful ones that
remind me a lot of the first JJ Abrams
Star Trek movie in addition to this it
seems like we're also going to be
getting the comic suits for the final
film where they're seeing several shots
of them dotting the blue leather ones
Drax no longer has sensitive nipples so
he'll also be putting one on as well
rocket ended up wearing one of these
suits in endgame so my guess is that
he's made some for the rest of the group
we even get the classic back-to-back
shooting shot that's been present in a
lot of films featuring the team it's a
callback to when Rocket and Groot did it
at the prison before Baby Groot did it
on Rocket anyway we see them diving in
space towards a fleshy structure this is
later revealed to be the high
evolutionaries base I love how there's
this flesh-like structure to the
spaceship and it shows how he's trying
to combine even minuscule things like
this in any way he can appears that it
even has hairs on it which is such a
cool detail you see him watching over a
white figure training and quill later
leaps out on a one I'm not sure exactly
who this is so if you know then drop it
in the comments below I'm guessing the
Guardians get caught as we see them in
what appears to be prison jumpsuits this
of course Echoes the first film in which
they were put in one as well now James
gonna said with this being his final
Guardians film that some characters will
die he said it's not going to be a
complete bloodbath like suicide squad
but that's some of our favorites will
end up going out you've already talked
about rocket but I'm guessing that Drax
will tude you today Batista confirming
this will be the last time he plays him
Drax has candy cane in the end of his
Arc and he got revenge on both Ronan and
Thanos who are responsible for his
family's death the MC recently has taken
in a big focus on the Afterlife with it
popping up in Moonlight though 11
Thunder and also wakanda forever I love
it if we saw Drax reunite with his
family after passing away nothing would
be the perfect way to end his ark now
due to all the connections to Earth
Rockets Origins and the high
evolutionary I do feel like Peter will
end up returning there for good this was
the planet at which his mother died and
it makes sense that he'd want to avoid
the place that gave him the most
traumatic experience of his life however
he has been there from time to time I
think the movie might culminate with him
moving back there and finally going back
to the family that he was abducted from
at the start of the first movie now we
also see the monster that the team
fought at the start of the second
guardian's film but it's use here I'm
guessing that it's part of the high
evolutionaries creatures and he may have
even created the Beast that they fought
last time anyway we end with a nice
little joke now as for my thoughts on
the teaser I really dig it and the
Guardians have some of the best films in
the MCU under their belt James Gunn is
always really good at balancing the
comedy along with the more emotional
heartfelt moments I have a feeling that
he's gonna knock it out of the park for
his final swan song at Marvel this is
the culmination of the guardian's
journey and due to Disney being unable
to replace gun after firing him I don't
even know if these characters will
return in a major way due to directors
potentially not wanting to take over the
project hope we get the perfect ending
for them and this is a big movie before
gun goes after DC obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the trailer if
there's anything we missed or didn't
talk about then make sure you leave it
in the comments below we are in a
competition right now giving away three
copies of House of the dragon on the
15th of December and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teaser
you pick the comments at random on the
15th and the winners of the last one are
on screen right now similar to you then
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our Brighton of
the Indiana Jones trailer which will be
linked on screen right now lots of fun
talking about it little cool little
things there too so yeah definitely go
ahead over there right after this by the
way thanks for sticking to the video yo
I've been Paul I'll see you next time
take care peace